I get feeling something's bad is gonna
wait I came from this you I don't know
yet I can do backflips whoo okay let's
just go up here for something bad
happens
oh this is creepy Stefani I'm scared
I'll go first of all
no I'm not going oh oh [ __ ] Oh Stefan I
actually need you oh [ __ ] he's coming
over here oh don't make a nice bidet I
told you many times okay it's cool it's
cool
maybe I can use the phone as a decoy oh
[ __ ]
he saw me that sneaky [ __ ] I didn't
see me how can I know he wasn't even
looking at me I now route man Aram man
sorry I don't know what happened there
where's the phone though I need him why
am i underneath the stairs actually we
can leave him for now we can live
without him I'm good without phones
who needs it I don't nice I don't meet
anyone I'm all by myself in the darkness
and
scary and Stefano please come back
uh what is this wooden handle wouldn't
nice ah any do man there's nothing what
is this looks like a bathroom floor stay
in the box
didn't miss something
yes perfect
uh-huh oh I know I know I'm a genius
it's okay I know you know I know you
know you think you know my idea better
look at that that miniature penis gotta
be huge
miniature huge doesn't go well there
should be a something I'm genius comedy
means we still haven't used the portal
tingly tingly back yo yo
I'm pumped I'm pump Oh actually I'm not
so freaking pumped then I pick up boy
are we gonna go to report we're gonna do
now you scared scared really
I never get to ever I'm a man man men
don't get scared
what there's a ladder here
really something but Hollywood for now
alright so there is Lions shooting laser
beams I sing that before many times
what is this what is this ah I don't
understand all right let's go down later
go down let it go down lay I said go
down away there we go that makes perfect
sense
nothing dark and scary going on down
here
maybe we can tickle the nice balls well
I'll leave that for next episode
yo go let's go I get the feeling I'm not
supposed to be here but let's go let's
go why why can I go down here I don't
understand maybe I'm supposed to use a
potion or something yeah I was probably
supposed to use phony another I can
climb I'm a genius did you throw that
out of that you're like oh you're gonna
climb that no you didn't pass out of
that coincidence quinces what a
coincidence anyway let's touch that we
don't
and maybe rub it a lil just perfect I
don't know
uh-huh so hey what's going on right now
it's pretty exciting
I'm excited pretty
what hello lady did we write I think I
meaning son Alexander well I must find
him and put the end to this madness
right it might be coming staccato
I wonder if I find safar no in this
other world that would be pretty [ __ ]
epic never get home thank you thank you
mm-hmm thank you
there we go my daughter's Helen I'm
about to embark on what might very well
be the most important journey of in his
life my work has shown me that other was
do exist and I can travel to them please
understand my darling my classic country
is to cry to is that I must see that
these other words have to offer because
you're not enough lady do not worry Don
my love I will return soon and I will be
horny as I mean I will return bearing
the knowledge of these other reals I
will be able to use what I can learn
from them to expedite our own worlds
technology in a blah blah blah I love
you Helen I always have I always will
please understand I will see you soon
oh sorry Brock
yeah
go on stairs I wonder if there's like 60
monsters in this world [ __ ] [ __ ] I I
asked way too soon I asked I shouldn't
have asked I should just not
Stephano folks I'll piggy whoever
oh it's one with a thingy leading Glee
not a penis I mean just go here give us
tables
who doesn't like tables I liked it
tinderboxes conveniently play he's like
oh I got to leave my channel box here in
my lantern I don't know
and then just forget about it and then
the monster would be like oh hello oh
[ __ ]
vanna deputy pate that where's the fun
maybe he wants my pockets
Oster
oh I wonder if you see
easily it's fine the bucket works
function it's Donegan I'll just walk
like this
no problem
wait where was I okay I was going here
so many doors oh it's just a - monster
is it really
probably yeah but I have to check them
anyway
uh-huh uh-huh maybe this one is more fun
sup PT sir I'm firm let's go let's go
I'm snake pink oh yeah oh yeah and I
have a phone call no problem we can Wes
as plate
have you made by closing piggy I mean
his name figure I'm piggy what what I
know I don't wanna talk about all right
pick that up I need to answer my phone
[ __ ] hello hey Dave on arrival
uh-huh
okay
do it though yes okay stop
edit that out because it takes me
forever to edit out stuff so I'm sorry
you'll have to listen to me talking to
my dad sir
I'm Peggy I'm Peggy let's go let's go up
up that's all we can say it's pump aah
you made me waste my oil [ __ ] Kenny the
key in a fire key let's go I'm a snake
pee
actually I think I'm gonna leave piggy
here for now is that cool P yeah shoot
shoot
no Paul liberal what's this after
breaking I am the right get I feel so
much man what is this I have to record
voices the [ __ ]
okay that didn't happen maybe the what
really like what okay have a tiger I
have a key let's go I wish I could bring
tikki but
some other time what's this is where I
came from right for you know yeah this
is where I supposed to go
I'm a genius it's you
Oh
so we can either go here or we can go
there when I guess we can't go here yep
I'm a genius how we can go there this is
a really really long lon
really long let's go to the oh of course
of course there's a friggin storage
I don't like storages storages are
always bad using horror games I don't
think there's like no exceptions okay
it's like what do they want in the
storage I don't understand the bread
maybe the potatoes
maybe it's bold I mean I like bread and
is what give it back
just saying freaking snakes
don't see anything except yes or oil
breaks up you're in a barrel my bounds
where where do we go oh sweet
I have third is holy Shh that's the
extent of our anyway let's go
you guys don't notice that I have this
single pin about this last thing who did
that
and so it's so hard to orient wait what
is this
shrooms looks like something else I'm
not gonna say what it looks like
I'm just saying it looks like
wait what okay let's
Cinemark cinema cinema
uh-huh I'm a genius Oh
wonder if this works I guess once in a
lifetime
uh-huh I guess we can call this uh Hema
it's okay
what huh look what's going on uh who did
that who did that oh [ __ ] I don't even
away I'm I don't even I wa
well [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] like a
except on oh where is you where are you
gives a [ __ ] no man he's right there
I hate the exploding things oh [ __ ] I
thought he left the room
it's a barrels
[ __ ] sorry let's go thank you
oh [ __ ] he saw me
it's okay I got this
we call this Villa homicides
what the [ __ ]
leave me alone
come on leave me alone now
it's fun to play with the pottery yeah
okay okay just go just go what are we in
need in here I don't have to shake mine
what I hope you you go please
everyone want no one likes you
maybe the - doesn't like it it's even
mice come on let's go
oh [ __ ] he's talking through the barrels
I knew it I [ __ ] knew it
the barrels other team Oh
[ __ ] battles I'll talk to you later
my [ __ ] noodles [ __ ] barrels you
you I never ever all right uh listen up
of that let's go here I'll take that ya
ask me what it feel like seven a
disguise so Vendela telling Kurt Russell
homie this a real life I'll be making
good on my promises honesty his
confidence lot of it is missing but I
realize I could be better than I was
light on my feet cooking up the soul
when we fire up